restaurants across the valley working so
hard to stay open amidst the pandemic
with strict health guidelines and
capacity limits
it's been such a challenge for so many
to bring in customers
a news now reporter kate houston went to
a couple of restaurants today and she's
taking a look at how people
are staying open
hundreds of holiday decorations and
lights the owner tells me that this year
brought tremendous challenges
and she wants to end it on a bright note
from christmas trees to holiday
knickknacks
every corner of the building is covered
in decorations
each area has its own display including
the bathroom
the stage and the dining area with its
very own
20 20 christmas tree made out of toilet
paper
we have our study crowd and i want them
to be happy here
because they have kept us going through
all of this lori everetts and her team
started decorating the day after
thanksgiving
most of these decorations are donated
from customers and friends
evarts tells me this holiday cheer is
needed after more than eight months of
struggling to make ends meet
it's been horrible it's been scary it's
been
crying screaming not sleeping now evarts
hopes this winter wonderland will bring
in customers like andy strebel who want
a little bit of normalcy during an
otherwise difficult year
it's awesome it i'm kind of a ba humber
cause you know when i was young i love
christmas but i'm older and
coming here it kind of makes you get you
back in the spirit
although everett says it's been
difficult to keep up with changing
guidelines
she'll do whatever she needs to to stay
open we're looking to end the year
great hopefully in spite of what comes
with restrictions and everything
we're going to do what we're doing keep
pushing on
kate houston 8 news now thank you kate
while many businesses like the plate
bar and grill where kate was were able
to make it work with all their hard work
some had to permanently close their
doors due to the pandemic
the nevada restaurant association
projects that
30 percent 3 out of 10 restaurants will
close by the end of this year